all right so Game of Thrones is one of
the biggest TV shows of all time it had
a massive cultural impact and the
success of House of the Dragon shows
just how many people were invested in
the series when it originally launched
looking back at the show there's one
major moment in it that I think
completely changed television and that
is the red wedding a game changer it's
subverted expectations and ripped our
hearts out whilst delivering one of the
biggest twists of all time even watching
it almost 10 years later it's still
really impactful and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
why the scene works so well and how it
changed TV as a whole if you agree then
please hit the thumbs up button and also
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day if this is your
first time here I'm Paul welcome to the
heavy spoilers show now let's get into
the Red Wedding
okay so in order to discuss its impact
we have to talk about where television
was at at the turn of the Millennium the
medium was very much thought of as being
worse in film with production values and
the general feel of TV shows being cheap
in comparison of their big screen
counterparts this all changed at the
start of the century with TV networks
putting a lot of effort into their shows
to match the statue of movies AMC did a
big event in which it launched both
Breaking Bad and Mad Men and HBO started
pushing its fantasy series which was
called Game of Thrones George R.R Martin
had pitched the series for years but it
had been rejected due to his Pilot's
script being labeled as the most
expensive show of all time however HBO
took a chance on him and DND and the
show was eventually released its
popularity starred a snowball over time
and this is definitely down in the
complex characters that we loved and the
ones we love to hate season 1 was brutal
and ended with the death of Ned Stark in
what was a complete gut punch rarely had
we watched to protagonists be killed off
like this but in his wake we will left
following his wife and children as they
set out for Revenge the Lannisters were
complete pieces of [ __ ] and the family
were inbred like yeast which made them
easy to hate for months and months we
watched Rob Stark slowly man his quest
for Revenge with his family and it would
be difficult for anyone not to get
invested in him Against All Odds he won
battle after battle and this Underdog
Story was easy to become attached to now
for decades we've been trained by
Hollywood to expect stories like this to
go a certain way we have our clearly
defined heroes and villains and a
beginning middle and end that Bells
towards a showdown now if you'd ask
someone at the time what Game of Thrones
was about they probably would have said
at its core it's basically the Starks vs
the Lannisters sure there's the white
walkers the storyline with Dany but
these two sides were the major driving
points early on because of this
structure it was easy to get caught up
in believing that we were heading
towards a major showdown between the two
houses every time they took a shot
against a Lannister it felt like a win
for us too and rubbles are found in love
with Talisa the pair were married and
she fell pregnant making it seem like we
were gonna get a happy ending after the
death of our hero Ned it felt like the
show was just setting up for a major
Hollywood ending but this was all ripped
away at the Red Wedding and the first
brilliant thing that they do is they set
this event in episode nine this isn't
the season finale and because of this
you lured into thinking that the wedding
will happen we'll get a slow paced
episode that sets up things for the
finale and that will be where it all
goes down Rob had been building towards
a big battle with the Lannister's and it
just made sense that it would take place
in episode 10. for decades this is how
TV worked as well most of the time when
budgets were set out the first episode
would be where the majority of the money
went with it also being poured into the
finale most of the entries in between
this didn't have the amount given to
them that these two episodes did and
therefore audiences just expected these
to be run-of-the-mill since the arrival
of the Red Wedding we've seen how
several shows have flipped the script a
bit and actually put their big events
before the finale which I believe this
series at the tone for Ned also died in
the episode before the ending it seemed
like a formula they crafted for success
to ensure people would come back for the
next episode this is seen from the
opening of the entry which starts off
pretty simple Rob stands with Catelyn
looking over a map in order to plan out
an attack that we are supposed to assume
will happen in episode 10. this is to
take Taiwan Lannister's Castle who at
this point is one of the big bads
Catelyn says show them how it feels to
lose what they love and it very much
sets the stage for what we think is
going to be preparing the next episode
from here we go to Walter Frey who feeds
the stocks and their forces this shows
friendship and the food has passed
around cementing how they all eat from
the same plate hammering home the idea
of trust this of course subliminally
makes us get lured into a false sense of
security much like the characters Ray
parators daughters out there like some
medieval take me out and he reminds Rob
of the word that he ended up breaking
one of these women were meant to be
Queen but Robin and back on the deal
after giving a YouTuber level apology
for breaking his word it seems like All
Is Forgiven and edmia marries Roslyn
there's a great line that foreshadows
what's to come and it sets up the
eventual path of the episode the wine
will flow red
and the music will play Loud
and we'll put this mess behind us now
interestingly the title of the entry
gives away the ending and if you looked
at this beforehand then it might clear
you into the twist call the reins of
Castamere this is a famous Tune In The
Song of Ice and Fire that celebrates how
the Lannisters destroyed the house of
rain when they dare to rebel against
them the song is also played at the
wedding and this happens when the tune
changes to Signal exactly what's going
on
[Music]
this is basically summarizing how
Lannister Always Pays their debts and
how they are stamming out Rob's
Rebellion once and for all music is a
big part of the turn at the end and
before the song switch they play The
Bear and the Maiden Fair it's basically
an upbeaten Jolly song that's used to
keep things light-hearted rather than
dark the bug actually gives us some
extra little details and this really
flashes out the scene throughout the
section Catlin constantly looks over to
the ban and remarks on how badly they're
playing in hindsight we know this is
obviously because they're soldiers and
not trained musicians and the wedding
itself is actually based on an event
from our own history in 1440 the UK was
still reeling off the death of King
James in 1437. Scotland was thrown into
a period of instability with James II
who was only six being announced as the
king vying for power with several people
including the Douglas's so those were
invited to a dinner on Edinburgh and
this event they were seized given a mock
trial and executed for treason Georgia R
Martin has been very open about taking
from British history in order to flesh
out his books and this is a prime
example of it the war was inspired by
hadron's wall which just so happens to
be down the road from where I live and
the tutors also provided inspiration for
the families now the rest of the episode
actually also Lewis isn't a thinking
we've seen the big action scenes John
ends up escaping the free folk after
playing his hand and killing arel bran
starts to master his work abilities and
Danny's crew take over a city seems like
the episode is very much par for the
course and here we could at the wedding
to see the ceremony playing out now
perfectly this lures the viewer into a
false sense of security too as they
believe they know what way things are
going to play out we've seen the big
action scenes and now it's time to have
the Calm before the storm that will
surely follow in the finale however at
the celebration things seem a bit off
Lord Bolton refuses drinks constantly
and Catelyn starts to notice things
stello these are characters that the
characters trust and therefore we do too
that's what makes this episode so
impactful because we also feel betrayed
as well not only are they killing the
characters they're killing the people we
love I've searched high and low for this
but that there was a TED Talk I remember
watching that discuss how we as people
gain attachments to fictional characters
and why they mean so much to us when you
think about it none of these people
exist he's unreal and yet we still love
them and there's even some that we
completely bring into our lives I'm a
massive Batman fan and the character has
become a big part of my life over the
years to almost becoming an obsession
during the Ted Talk they discussed a
survey that had been carried out and
this went over how strongly people love
their fictional characters when asked if
someone would rather have their favorite
character killed off or a real life
stranger as I'm sure you can guess the
majority chose to save the fictional
person just look at your fellow people
in the comments below and focus on their
screen names ask yourself would you
either have your favorite fictional
character die over them and you can see
where I'm coming from writers and
creators have banked on this too and
there's the famous phrase don't be
afraid to Murder Your Darlings coined by
William Faulkner this piece of writing
advice basically means that you
shouldn't be afraid to kill off your
main characters it says that when a
character is served their purpose as a
writer don't be afraid to kill them off
it's something George RR Martin has done
a lot but even with this matter of the
stocks it feels like they still had so
much to do that's why we feel so robbed
and after the married couple are scored
off the doors are closed Rob and Talisa
discuss their unborn child and she
announces that they're gonna call it Ed
odd if it's a boy it's such a touching
moment and it reminds Robert what he's
fighting for his father is gone but
there's a chance they will rise up again
in this new child but it's not to be the
music changes Arya and cleganeh totally
before she can be reunited and Lord Frey
starts to give a speech Bolton smirks to
Catelyn and looks that is raised to
which we see he's wearing armor Talisa
is stabbed without a second to react and
Rob is spied with arrows before all the
Starks are butchered as part of Lord
Frey's wedding gift even revisiting this
scene the shock that comes from it is
such a gut punch it's difficult not to
relive it like it's your first time
watching it it's almost traumatic in a
sense and every time I put it on the
memories of the first time I saw it come
flooding back not even the direwolves
are safe and all of Rob's forces are
wiped out much to the horror of Arya we
are very much here in this moment
watching things play out helpless to
stop it Rob crawls the company's wife
but it's too late and we see she's gone
Catlin takes phrase wipe hostage and she
desperately begs for him to release his
son she's very much echoing the words of
the audience who are pleading that he at
least makes it out of there Our Minds
start to race imagining all the revenge
stories that he could go on and as much
as she begs for it to happen we know
deep down it'll never be the case
Caitlin and threatens to slip phrase
wipes throughout but he just replies by
saying On My Honor as italic
On My Honor as a stock
let him go
or I will cut your wife's throat
find another Robbie sends that by Bolton
and we cut to Catelyn who does some
cutting of her own she's devastated and
we hold on to her she just stands there
and able to move much like the audience
she too is killed and like us she's
completely robbed of all her emotion at
this point there's no fight left in her
I remember just sitting there completely
wiped out even her death just leaves you
feeling empty and we cudded the credits
which has no music over the top of it
not even kidding it just hangs there
without anything playing behind it it
leaves this feeling of bleakness loss
and Devastation in every way it's easy
to see why this episode's impact has
lasted for so long and is something that
a lot of TV shows have tried to take the
structure of in order to add their own
gut punches this was the first time I
really remember something fictional
completely flattening me and it felt
like a point in which TV turned no
longer are we saying what TV lacked in
comparison to a film but instead we were
appreciating the fact that the medium
provided New Opportunities now we had
the chance to tell stories that didn't
fit the Hollywood formula and instead of
wrapping things up in a two hour run
time we could divert throw curveballs
and kill off characters for overlocking
narratives it really changed TV and the
way that people try to tell stories and
rather than matching movies the creators
try to do something different overall
the Red Wedding still stands as a major
gut punch and it's something that
changed television history obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in a competition right now giving
away three copies of top gun Maverick on
the 15th of November and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now so that's you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
even smells to watch make sure you check
out one of our house of the dragon
videos on screen right now we've had a
lot of fun talking about the series so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace